war is the only business in this
industrial park
the once bustling factory now a
bristling front line
ukrainian soldiers say russia-backed
separatists are only a few dozen meters
away
almost daily they make their presence
known including as a top general paid a
visitor
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been told to move out of this area
quite quickly we heard some gunfire from
the russia-backed separatists the front
line is very close to where we are
we move to a safer distance
incidents like this are routine for
those based here but ukraine is starting
a new round of military exercises in the
north and the south of the country a
response to russia massing more than a
hundred thousand troops around its
borders
the head of all ground forces had a
message for the russian soldiers
but this is a town that's already
suffered so much
apartments scarred after separatists
tried but failed to take control of
avdevka in 2017.
lives also shattered like those of
nine-year-old sasha and her grandmother
she was only four when a shell exploded
near a house she was visiting with her
mom
my mama
they only have each other now
a priceless bond with so much else
broken
debra haynes sky news avdevka in eastern
ukraine